so I've always been interested in why
countries appear and disappear and the
curious thing is how often it happens so
three quarters of the flags borders and
anthems sitting at the UN today we're
not there 60 some-odd years ago and
today in Europe you're talking about
whether England is going to remain a
part of Great Britain or Scotland or
Wales or parts of France or parts of
Italy or parts of Belgium or parts of
Holland and as countries appear and
disappear then I began to ask what makes
country successful and it turns out
after a long slog through geographies
and ethnicities and all kinds of
variables it's the ability to adapt and
adopt that Darwin talked about that
really makes a difference and that led
me to technology and then I ended up in
genomics
so the really important thing is that
one not remain illiterate the difference
between people who can read and write
and those who can't
it's just apps a astronomical and and
the problem is the definition of whose
litter and who's not keeps changing so
in you know Neanderthal times if you
painted on a cave wall that was enough
to transmit how you hunt how you eat how
you cook how you dress and we can read
about that we can go to a cave wall in
France or in Argentina and see that
eventually that became codified into
hieroglyphs and when we did that we
standardized language and we put it on
Pyrus or clay and moved it and that
allowed us to have holy books that
allowed us to have military strategy
customs unions agricultural manuals we
went from tribes to empires because we
could transmit data across space and
time eventually that became a 26 letter
alphabet in English 29 letters in
Spanish thousands of letters and Chinese
and that alphabet allowed us to typeset
create giant books create giant
libraries and it was enough to generate
the Renaissance in the Industrial
Revolution but over the last thirty
years what's happened is we've moved
into ones and zeros and in doing so we
took every letter written and spoken in
English every word written in spoken
English and put it into a one and A zero
and French and Cyrillic and Aramaic and
Chinese and every language on the planet
well the second thing that happened as
we collapsed every bit of music in every
tonal scale and every photograph and
every video and every film and every
website and in the process of doing that
we can now take huge libraries and bring
them into our laptops and that has to
change the way in which we earn our keep
it's changed the global economy changed
is rich and it was poor to the point
where I'd argue that most of the wealth
generated over the last thirty years has
come out of the ability to use and apply
ones and zeros digital code that's where
the e base
Microsoft's Hewlett Packard's Google's
etc et-cetera et-cetera come from now
what's beginning to happen is we're
beginning to shift into digital into
life cut and in the process of shifting
in the life code every life form on this
planet is coded in a double helix with a
sugar phosphate backbone and that codes
whether you become a bacteria an orange
a lemon a limb or a cow a sheep a human
being a politician any one of these
things is all coded in this four-letter
code there are subtleties to it there's
epigenomics there's expression there's a
whole series of things but basically
it's four letters making all life forms
as we understand that just as from the
1970s onward digital code started to
drive the global economy now life code
is beginning to be the fundamental
driver of the global economy over the
next 10 20 30 years